Let's go to Tommy in the 2 0 2 who we have
flagged as an A.I.
Biden guy.
Tommy, where are you at these days?
But back now.
So what's up?
The Democrats are monsters mad as that stunt
they pulled yesterday.
I. I am absolutely disgusted by that.
And by that I mean, which stunt?
You mean just like voting when there's a virus?
Yes.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean, listen, yeah.
How do you have a president saying you shouldn't
gather in groups of more than 10?
And then you have a couple million people
voting.
I just don't get it.
I don't understand.
You know, it's it's crazy.
I mean, in many ways, it kind of just.
Listen, I'm at this point the Democrats are
just basically in the same type of breed of
monsters that these Republicans are.
You could say that.
Yeah, well, at the very least, Republicans
are still kind of worse.
We'll start with some of the things that they
do.
Right.
It's it.
I'm genuinely disgusted right now.
And I'm like, you know what?
I'm looking at the situation about the Bernie's
vote and Bernie's reasons for failures at
this point.
I got like five reasons why he failed.
Number one, that that endorsement wave that
came with all the people dropping out and
going to support Joe Biden got number two.
The mainstream media brainwashing that keeps
happening was awful.
I live he got a family member rally with his
straight up.
Joe Biden's a whole anti-ISIL security history
thing that has been obfuscated that his father
before complicating it
is that I'm like I literally have visual evidence
of him lying about that.
How are you?
How were you not seeing that?
Then we got situations of older voter turnout
and it's like what happened to the youth.
Right.
I'm thinking maybe you know what?
Because as far as I understand it, the stats
said straight up the youth turnout was basically
similar to happen four years ago with the
last vote election versus the older turnout,
which is just everybody just coming in and
math.
I don't understand how that happened.
I generally don't stand.
And that means me to think that there's probably
some more truth to this whole thing.
My fourth reason rigged.
Because I understand that's a dirty word for
a lot of people.
But you know what?
First off, the Iowa situation.
Yeah, did.
And there's no other explanation for that.
After that point, when you said we're not
even though correct the record.
Piss off.
No.
Okay.
Now hold on a second because you're you are
shot out of a cannon today.
And let me see if we can maybe diffuse a little
bit.
The one thing I want to ask you is, does this,
Bernie, bear any responsibility in the sense
that like you, do you think Bernie benefited
or not from the Democratic Socialist label?
What do you think of that as it is just as
an example?
Oh, yeah, that's that's actually necessary.
OK, Bernie Sanders, do nice.
But Bernie Sanders but us does not obey the
radar.
Let's not mince words.
Too nice versus saying you're a democratic
socialist.
Those are two different things, right?
Like I believe it was damaging to to keep
going with that label.
I've been saying it for five years.
Do you agree that self-inflicted.
Right.
Yeah, I've read that book.
I also think that straight up in a way when
I say too nice, I mean that you need to more
aggressively say the problems of love, a Biden
presidency versus a birdie presidency.
And like how Kyl was saying you need to make
the case that I'm the moderate centrist, I'm
the one who's actually got more your interests
at heart because I have your interests at
heart.
I'm better at being Donald Trump.
The record he barely did.
You tell me.
Let me give you another question.
Time me again.
I just.
I'm trying to hear where your head's at.
In every poll over the last two weeks, that
does a hypothetical match up.
Biden versus Trump and Bernie versus Trump.
Biden performs better.
Do you think those polls are just wrong or
are people lying when they respond to the
pollsters?
Feel this way at this point.
All the Trump, I think is the favorite to
win.
Well, at least Trump has a better chances
of winning based on the things that's happened,
whether he's going against Bernie or Joe Biden.
I think Bernie has a better chance of beating
Donald Trump because, again, Joe Biden, he's
running on the type of platform that Clinton
did back in 2016, on type of platform that
John Kerry did back in 2004.
That's a risk right off.
Far as I'm concerned, I'm like it.
Those polls, especially because of how close
they are.
Yeah, a lot of them.
I'm just like.
I don't even know are you are.
Who are you voting for in November?
You know what?
That is what marriage is like.
Joe Biden is me.
He's too conservative.
I'm sorry, but I'm going to have to disagree
with you when it comes to like a Supreme Court
picks and climate change.
No, look, Tommy, I'm just asking.
Who usually only say November?
Who are you voting for November?
Joe Bottom better come get my vote because
here's the thing, is that this thing he would
he had gold form and the fact that he's better
at health care than Trump.
Right.
More people will probably be covered under
him.
The.
He'd better not move to the right on that.
OK, I got a lot of general.
You qualify to Hanen from the 2 0 2.
Always great to hear from you, my friend.
Hackler Tommies Underwhelm there with my wrap
up of his his phone call.
OK.
Let's go next to the 7 7 3 area code.
Who's calling today from 773?
I am.
And who's this?
This is Michael.
Michael, what's up?
So.
I was disappointed that some of my fellow
burning growers are voting for Donald Trump
if he doesn't win.
I don't think they should do that.
If who doesn't win?
Burning oil, burning, winning right now.
No, it's over.
It's over.
Yeah.
Mm hmm.
When I heard you say it's over.
I was disappointed, but yeah.
I was old enough to vote.
Who are you voting for in in November?
Not old enough to vote for it if I was, I
would vote for Joe Biden.
I know Trump, right.
I think that's the right that's the right
attitude.
Michael.
All right.
How you holding up with the virus?
Mindframe Home.
However, I did get some work from my school.
You did?
And it is hell, yeah.
Are you, Michael?
Mm hmm.
How old a guy are you?
One more time.
What's your age?
Michael, how old of a person are you?
I'm only 16.
You're 16.
Okay, so you're like a high school is canceled
for the rest of what?
The semester?
The year?
It's canceled until March 30th, I think.
Oh, and then they're going to reevaluate.
Yeah.
All right, Michael, very good.
Anything else you wanted to mention today?
So I'd be scared of the Corona virus.
Should you be scared?
Did you say?
Yeah, well, it's not about being scared, it's
about being cautious and acting responsibly,
so when when we're told, listen, limit your
exposure unless necessary.
Stay home.
So on and so forth.
It's not about being scared.
Won't do anything for you, but being cautious
and having a plan will.
And it sounds like you're doing that by by,
you know, doing schoolwork from home and all
of that.
Yeah.
OK, Michael, thanks very much.
Excellent to hear from Michael
in
the 773 area code.